only to virus which we do not even know
a little virus
unless of Hanna what's a little not she
was seen you know what I am in control
just didn't everybody know this journey
this road that I travel on it all seems
crazy over the years I picked up
thousands and Tagalongs inspired by my
story from a tree for now where my
clothes had holes in them
I'm afro is picky to the night east
maschino and Versace nice no laces inner
Archie's new millennium ceremony Kawada
her to lay their care to brothers and
sisters and dear friends before I start
one appraisal loss of Hannah what I love
the most merciful the most just or
praise His glory and better to belong to
him I came to Turkey loss Monday night
Tuesday morning for a little break for a
longer day Angela I also had a few
things to do as well
soif are just people for them at the
same time and then we saw the escalation
of the corona virus in the UK increasing
and as far as I know right now in Turkey
I've been told that you know people have
been told to stay away from crowded
places some people will send back from
work so their muscles getting serious
now there is a lot of things that we can
learn from this you know and we should
as Muslims reflect you know because
Alyce's understood and in surah anaam
verse 194 m statement in Nephi Hulk is
Sumati well our diversity laughing
lately when I heard in the creation of
the heavens and earth and in the
alternation of the night and day there
are signs for those who have wisdom one
who you know use the intellect and we
have to use our intellect so it's not
just science you know we look at the
creation of the heavens in the earth and
in the alternation of the night and date
but when we look around us these signs
yeah be it diseases whatever it may be
as muslims what do we take from this now
the first first thing that we need to
acknowledge and understand brothers and
sisters is that the chaos that's
happening so you see like you know black
friday sales etc when people burn and a
mad one trying to kick people in the
face you know take people's eyes out for
the TV they already have at home
it's just psychological you know yes i
need to go get something why I don't
know I just need to go and get it so
we're in this cave now this time it's
not TV it's not computer it's toilet
walls now I'm very curious why told it
was you know I think in the least case
there are that's gonna happen is you're
just gonna need water to walk what's
your backside you know and maybe use a
towel or something to dry it you know no
need to fight over toilet lows but when
you see Muslims falling for this and
acting like animals you know and
behaving like animals we should be
people that don't only just care about
our self or others but does it not
listen to be learned from this than
other lesson that we should learn from
this is the following
look how people are acting because there
is a disease that we do not know that
they are acting like is your milk Liana
this is the day of judgment now this is
not even a matter of people going to the
fire on all so if people are so selfish
when it comes to their self over a
toilet roll imagine that they a judgment
when they will be thrown into the fire
the very people that you follow
celebrities Muslim youtubers myself
whether it may be you know we're gonna
be caring about ourselves
and uh I will be going about my own
business I'll be caring about myself
nobody else another thing that is
profound and I think is that hikmah
between behind coronavirus is that we
can't come and say okay first it's title
okay maybe it's a punishment for China
maybe maybe not
however I think this is a warning to all
of us because before I will think to
myself people even we live in a selfish
stuff times we look up all insisted and
we've become desensitized in Syria and
people being blown up into pieces and we
thought that would never happen to us
well guess what allies were dropping
bombs on us but the whole wide entire
world is now on the verge of panic
paranoia who's good at somebody now we
are afraid to come out our houses just
like our brothers and sisters who are
afraid to come out because bombs not
before me now unless that Hannah Watauga
has a Sunnah to make us feel that fear
and Allah says in the Quran that he will
test us with fear with loss of life and
wealth etc etc etc and fear is one of
those now we live in absolutely have the
different virus the virus we live in in
that field and Allah will do that when
you care about yourself when you turn
away from the coronation and who you
care about is making money increasing
your lifestyle you know buying new shoes
clothes etc when you only care about
yourself the fear will come into your
very household and that's exactly what's
happening that's point number one point
number two of this is one touch upon is
that there is a hadith of the prophet
sallallaahu verse element which states
the following and I saw this on study
areas possums fan to fan the propeller
Salim said immorality never appears
amongst of people to such an extent that
they committed commit it openly but
plagues and diseases that were never
known among the predecessors will spread
among among them
subhanAllah if this is not a saint if
this is not a sign new
diseases where people are committing
immorality one of the senses their
judgment is that people would have in
fornication out on the streets and the
best amongst them will be the ones who
would come and see them look at least
got behind the world that's gonna be the
best among them look you can do it just
do it behind it what that's what the
best amongst them you know when that
happens these diseases are going to
reveal what we need to understand is the
following
yeah that you are living in God's planet
if you don't want to obey his laws leave
the planet well you can vote too when we
say you know I'd have to delight up in a
little crazy belong to the Lord of whole
entire mankind yeah anyway you go
belongs to him you choose not to obey
Him this is what happens now this some
of you might see this as harsh
you know you the public of evil you've
got hold on a second what about all the
transgressions that we do towards God
all the transgressions that we do and
he's given us so many blessings but we
choose to go and do the evil acts the
haraam acts you were so many juices but
even through alcohol so many meats what
you want to eat poop you know and I'm
talking to you know Muslims and those
who you know in general that's point
number two for us to learn point number
three which I found really profound is
when this happens it lead to virus which
we do not even know a little virus Allah
subhana wa sahlan I'm not sure seen you
know what I am in control just didn't
everybody know that Allah is basically
and in other show you can say see him
look I'm in control what's happening in
India China oppression whoever whoever's
going on around the world so the Muslims
is whoa this is a severe warning to the
Muslims as well he fled for an
additional Allah seen I am in total
control
Allah is an absolute control and he's
good you know who the real boss is so he
can humble yourself down don't walk on
the earth proudly because your feet
cannot you know open up the earth
it's a lesson for us to humble yourself
because the one who is control of the
earth and the universe is there any no
and little virus just a little virus
that you can't even maybe detected
yourself and can't even see it you know
you can only see the symptoms you know
you know I'll send a little thing you
know and that'll cause panic later on
something severe that's for number three
now point number four brothers and
sisters as Muslims we should know better
what can we do to help our wider
community not myself going by toilet
rolls fight to the fight over it punch
people this is disgusting behavior
you're absolutely pathetic as Muslims we
should know I heard a copper in Scotland
is different little medical kids we got
a beautiful guys to give to their
neighbors yeah
this is how as Muslims we should be how
can I help somebody else rather helping
myself you know so let's think and plan
and think you know how can I help my
neighbors is their elderly you know we
should have as Salam our organization
work planning okay how can we help the
elderly Muslim or non-muslim you may not
be able to come at their house they're
vulnerable
how can we do their shopping etc we're
thinking of ways how can we do that as a
Salaam Organization you know that is
what we plan to do and I'm sure I ever
and other organizations are doing the
same as well how can we help other
people that's point number four points
number five that's this issue of the net
carb and now the niqab ban is pretty
funny now because it was like you know
security risk
you know the nation's who use it as a
security risk you know and we want to
see the faces oppression how can you
have communication with someone that
come as their face interesting very
interesting we know it so interesting
I'm gonna put my feet up
and address this issue like that you
know in this manner it's so interesting
because the thing is now is shown that
this is not a matter of security this is
not a matter of how you're going to
communicate with someone you can't see
when you communicate with a lot of
people over the phone that you don't see
any of the communication you know you
understand each other you know you're
talking yeah and the niqab doesn't stop
it covers me Nisha enough you know now
that has exposed these islamaphobe
countries all of these countries maybe
France wherever it may be that are have
a problem within a club then a carbon
it's not in a carb and all these people
be it Muslims whatever it may be their
problem is not that the problem they
have is with Islam
these are just excuses this has shown
that now people are covering their faces
you're not coming up the houses you know
you can have communication with these
people you can talk to these people
they're not a security risk
yeah you can have all of these now it's
come tonight that's look that's not the
issue
so let just expose them so there's a lot
of wisdoms behind it and reasons why
things happen even if it's for a reason
it's important as Muslims for us to
reflect upon it and I'm gonna finish on
this no brothers and sisters that's once
again 100 in love we should this should
be a sign for us to get closer to allah
subhana wa sahlan
this should get closer to us understand
enough for an extraneous set of turning
our back against it and involving
indulging in the modi affairs where
allah subhanallah al has put everything
to hurt the the markets are collapsing
yeah people don't know how they're going
to survive
yeah this shows you that one little
virus can flip the whole thing upside
down and I hope
this is a reminder for us to show who is
reading control our lost have Hannah
rotala and he is control of all your FS
everything so put your trust in him if
you possibly do to this we know that if
somebody the first has some said it dies
for plague but certain diseases etc they
will die as a martyr inshallah be
patient look after the vulnerable the
elderly your parents non-muslim Muslim
take care of the rights of Korean
community as a whole instead of being
selfish like animals and fighting one
another learn to share because your risk
what is destined for you is going to
reach you so don't think you're taking
somebody else's you just you're just
posing yourself similar so in shut up
over the sisters that's about it for me
I probably give you guys a no reminder
and a little just a little light drop on
the side this is the reason why Turkey
has maybe needed no cases of this virus
here's a little video which I took in
the toilet please check it out to next
time assalamualaikum what I have to
write back here